NOAH LEVIN: So quick question.
How many of you in the room have
used a prototyping tool before,
or one of the tools
maybe listed up here?
Just raise your hand.
Oh, my.
That's awesome.
I actually didn't expect that.
That's really, really great.
I'm super excited to
facilitate a conversation
about these tools and
why they matter for us.
And actually, while
we're talking,
I want you to think about
questions at the end,
because I will say there's
not been a lot of questions.
So just prepare
now, and write down
little doodles or
notes of things.
I'm totally going to
just hope that there's
amazing questions afterward.
The first thing I
wanted to point out
was that you'll notice on
this panel there's not really
any representation from
traditional design tools
you might have thought about.
Right?
There's not anyone here from
something like Photoshop
or Sketch, even though we spend
a lot of time in those tools.
These are all people who've
created interactive tools,
yet we still chose to call the
panel Design Tooling and not
something like Prototyping
to kind of make
a statement about where we
think these tools are headed.
We really think it's
the next evolution
of the medium of the tools
we use and what we work on.
So I think we've used static
mockmaking tools for a while,
and they worked
really, really well
in a world where we
were creating things
like business cards and
book covers and posters.
But now with our devices,
we touch, we drag,
we swipe, we play,
in some cases,
we speak with our devices.
And yet we're using tools
that don't necessarily
represent that.
Right?
We're using these
flat, static tools,
and I think it's mostly
because it's easier.
Right?
There's not really much
of a better option.
It's just kind of the
best that we have.
And I think what
I'm excited about is
I think that's starting
to change, thanks a lot
of the people you see here.
So I think a common
scenario that
might sound kind of
familiar to many of you
is you're in a meeting room--
some combination of maybe
product managers,
engineers, and designers--
and you're looking up at a
screen in some kind of room,
and that screen has a
picture of a phone on it.
And that picture has a bunch
of pictures inside of it,
and you're kind of
clicking through a bunch
of different mockups, and you're
making some pretty important
decisions at that
point sometimes.
You're starting to kind
of critique things,
the way things look, the
way things are placed,
but it kind of feels productive.
You know?
You're making decisions.
You're making tradeoffs.
And at a certain point, you
make enough of those iterations
that you decide, OK, it's time.
Let's hand it off to engineers.
So you hand it off to engineers,
and in a couple of weeks,
or depending on the size of
the product you're working on,
maybe a few months, you
finally get this demo.
And you get this
demo in your hands,
and finally, your eyes
kind of start to light up,
and the conversation starts
to change a little bit.
All of a sudden,
we're not focused
on the pixels that were
off on the projector,
but we're talking about
the flow in our hands,
and we're having a productive
conversation at this point.
And unfortunately, sometimes
at that point in the process,
you might realize a
lot of those decisions
you made weren't as
good as you thought.
And it's expensive to make
changes at this point.
You've made a lot
of assumptions.
You've built this whole thing.
It sucks to have
to go back on that.
And I've actually seen this
happen all the time at Google,
and it's something
we're actually
trying to work on and
get a lot better at.
And fortunately, we can,
because today, again, we
have these new
tools that allow us
to skip to the field
part a lot sooner.
And I think even without
like a CS degree or staring
at kind of a monospaced
wall of text,
we have these more
visual tools now,
and we can things interactive
in a matter of days
instead of waiting months, which
I think is really important.
So thanks to a
lot of these tools
like Form and Pixate and
Origami and Framer and Invision.
We can hand around our devices
and ask people to try it,
as opposed to just kind
of imagining and making
a lot of assumptions and filling
in the gaps in your own way.
But even with all of the
different-- this explosion
of all of these new
tools, there hasn't really
been a lot of
conversation about it.
There hasn't even been really a
whole lot of press or articles
on the subject.
I read one by Pasquale
D'Silva that felt pretty good,
but it was one of
the only ones I
could find about these tools,
these interactive tools.
And so we're really
excited to actually
have a conversation
about these things,
and I hope that inspires us to
continue to have conversations
about the tools
that we use and how
it affects our process, how
it makes better products.
And so to start
this conversation,
we're going to go around and
introduce ourselves, and maybe
just say your name, where
you're from, and how you-- just
to start with something
light-- how you came up
with the name for your
product, and if there were
other names you'd
considered beforehand.
We'll start with Adam, because
his tool's name is particularly
appropriate for the
conference we're at today.
ADAM DEBRECZENI: Hey, guys.
My name's Adam.
I work on Form by Relative Wave.
Thanks for coming
to our conference.
I'm really excited.
Google got to sponsor it.
Our first code name
for the project
was called Tango, and going
along with the line of Google
taking our product names,
Google announced Project Tango,
and we couldn't use it anymore.
So we went to Form, because
for the longest time,
our ethos for the
project was, how
do we make a tool
that's really malleable?
How do we make a
tool that survives
15 years down the line?
And we kind of see Form as kind
of transcending mobile phone
prototyping and doing
something down the line.
PAUL COLTON: Hi, there.
My name is Paul Colton.
I'm the founder of Pixate.
I was actually born
outside of Venice, Italy,
but lived most of my life here.
For us, how we came
up with the name,
I actually came up with
the name before we even
knew what we were
going to build.
I knew it was going to be about
pixels in motion, if you will.
I knew that much.
Pixar.com wouldn't
sell me their domain,
so I went ahead and
went with Pixate.
Interesting side note-- it was
an Apple employee that sold us
the domain he was
holding personally.
And the other
interesting part, just
I thought I'd
throw out there, is
we use 99 designs for
our little flower logo,
and it was interesting
getting back 600 or 700 logos
and whittling it down to one.
So I feel like it was kind
of community-driven for us,
and then that essentially we
used that name for the product
that we were going to build.
KOEN BOK: Well, I'm Koen.
I make Framer.
And the story about our
name is very boring,
so I'll keep it short.
There's a guy here in the
audience, and he told me,
you should call it Framer.
It's a cool name.
I liked it.
So that's kind of
what we settled on.
BRANDON WALKIN: Hey.
I'm Brandon Walkin.
I'm a product
designer at Facebook.
I worked there for
about five years,
and I built Origami
while working on Paper,
so I was part of the team
there, and we worked on it
for two years, and
I basically built
Origami in my spare time
while working on that.
And in terms of a name,
I think I actually
know as a roommate, who's
one of our design managers
named Austin Bales
came up with the name.
And I think we just wanted to
reference two things-- one,
craftsmanship.
And another is-- so
Origami played a big role
in designing Paper,
and so we thought
it'd be pretty cool if
there was some consistency
between the names there.
CLARK VALBERG: I'm
Clark from Invision.
You might know me from
Brooklyn, or maybe your inbox.
We invented Invision
at a consulting company
that I ran before Invision.
And we invented it--
is this the question
I'm supposed to be answering?
We invented it to solve the
problem of socializing design
process, so we felt
like things were broken.
Too many of the
design conversations
we were having were
one-on-one, and we
wanted to allow
people to be included
in the vision of the product.
I may have just made that up.
I'm not sure.
NOAH LEVIN: Awesome.
So we're going to just take
you through a couple of themes
and questions within
those themes that we think
capture some of the problems
we're trying to solve
and some of the
interesting topics
that we're going to go
over, and just start.
We want you to
hopefully come away
with this thinking
about why this matters,
and if you haven't
already tried these tools,
why you might want to.
And so I guess just to get
things started, let's go around
and talk about some
of the inspiration
for creating your tool.
Like what drove you to do it?
And actually we'll
start with Adam,
and kind of go along
in the same way.
ADAM DEBRECZENI: Yeah, we
started working on the tool
about a year and a half
ago, so time flies.
It's crazy that
we're here on stage.
We were working on a
client project at the time,
and we were building
this 3D model
editor for this client who
wasn't overtly technical.
And it was very difficult
conveying the concepts and just
PNGs.
So we would send her
a PNG on her iPad,
and she would be
zooming in and out,
not understanding how
the interface worked.
And I played around with
ways of making-- or trying
to convey what I was trying
to do with a 3D model editor
and just sending
the client an mp4.
It showed the result of
what we wanted to create
but didn't let you
actually interact with it.
So we tried to build a
tool just for ourselves,
and then we quickly
realized, as I was just
talking to friends
in the industry,
that this is a very common
problem that a lot of people
have.
NOAH LEVIN: How about you, Paul?
How did you guys-- what
inspired you to create Pixate?
What are the things that led
to you guys creating this?
PAUL COLTON: Literally before
we wrote a line of code,
we said, we're not going to try
to guess what we need to build.
We went out and spoke
with many of you honestly.
Just every designer who would
have our meeting-- Twitter,
Pinterest, and a whole
list, but beyond.
And we said, what are your
pains, and how can we fix them?
And I'll just mention too real
quick that I'm sure all of you
have-- when I personally
heard things like,
we make After Effects movies,
so then we can show that
to somebody about
what we intend,
I don't know.
I cringed about that,
because that was like, well,
what if you have
to make a change?
And how do you make
variations of this movie?
Can you interact with that?
Of course, we know the
answer to all of those.
And then the other
thing we heard
was, oh, we hand
it to engineering.
Engineering spends three weeks
prototyping an idea, only
to have someone say,
it doesn't work.
I mean that's, to me, was
like-- I mean I felt their pain.
I wanted to run out of the
meeting and start implementing.
But we talked to
lots of companies,
and we literally just set out to
build exactly what they needed,
and that's effectively
what we've started with
and were able to keep
going from there.
NOAH LEVIN: Nice.
And how about Koen?
What inspired you guys?
KOEN BOK: Yeah,
so for us, there's
actually kind of two
parts to this story,
and the first part is
pretty close to Brandon.
I was also working at
Facebook-- not on Paper,
but on other stuff.
And I was also trying
to invent a way
to just do better
and faster work,
and iterate faster on IDs.
So I found a way to
sort of hack together
existing technologies that
we knew like Photoshop
and JavaScript, and
get that down quickly.
And it stayed like
that for quite awhile
until I left Facebook.
And after that, we
started thinking
about what are the
biggest problems with that
for designers to actually
pick this up and start using?
So how do we get designers
to start learning code?
How do we get this
sort of framework
to give you live
direct feedback?
And that's what
we tried to solve
in this sort of second
coming of Framer,
and that's where we are now.
BRANDON WALKIN: Yeah.
Well, the first time I
started using Quartz Composer
was actually when Mike
Maddess joined Facebook.
He brought Quartz
Composer with him,
and he was just building
these incredible prototypes,
like things we've just
never seen earlier.
And it was just like totally
different from the work
that we were doing at the time.
So we saw that, and
we were like, OK,
we have to get to that level.
This is where everyone's
going to be in a few years.
And so at that point, we
started using Quartz Composer,
and Quartz Composer is
this really old tool.
It wasn't even built
for prototyping,
and so we found a lot
of inefficiencies in it
and just started building
UI design abstractions
on top of it.
And we built it for ourselves
while we were designing Paper.
We had all these ideas, and we
wanted to actually get them out
in prototypes.
And so yeah, we actually
built Origami to do that.
And then we just wanted to
share that with the world,
and so we shipped it.
CLARK VALBERG: So we developed
Invision in an answer to,
I think, a couple of
conspiring factors.
One was I think that designers
were engaging with some of what
were [INAUDIBLE] looked at as
kind of academic approaches
to design, like usability
testing and real user testing
and some of the things
that people tend to do when
a product's already
been launched,
and they're trying to figure
out what to do with it next.
People were doing that
during the design process.
And people were engaging their
end users, their stakeholders,
and the multiple
networks of stakeholders.
Not only like the main
product leads, but also
real users, and VPs,
and domain experts.
And we needed a
place that allowed
all of that
conversation to happen,
and we needed a really
low investment way
for the product to iterate and
to evolve in a process of kind
of design discovery
in reaction to that.
So we wanted to make
sure that whatever tool
we built required very little
investment from the designer
and was extremely flexible
the whole way through
so that the story could
really come through.
NOAH LEVIN: Yeah, I think
it's really interesting
to hear even a little
bit of contrast
in the backgrounds of
how each of these people
made their tools.
You're having some that are
sort of more observational
that you're going and
interviewing various designers
and learning about the problems
they're having, and how to
fix them.
And you can kind of step back.
Maybe you have your own
understanding being designers
on the panel, but
it can be different
than maybe you see your own
problems that you're facing,
and you're solving
them for yourself.
Yet we still kind of end up
with a somewhat similar result
in being able to-- seeing
this need for being
able to prototype faster.
So the next thing
I want to ask is
why did it take up until now?
Honestly, I think even like
three years ago, at most,
people might have prototyped a
little bit with some web code,
or maybe used Keynote, and I
think a lot of people still do.
But a lot of the tools that
you guys represent up here
are pretty new.
And what do we think took
so long to make that happen?
I know, Paul, you had
some thoughts on this.
PAUL COLTON: Yeah, actually
we were chatting last night
or this morning--
it's all a blur now--
but the idea is how can
it be that all of a sudden
we're all here on stage?
I didn't know about these
guys when I started.
I mean seriously.
And I mean it's awfully
interesting that how could
we have all these different
ways of prototyping
and all converge to this
point in this room today?
And I rewound, and I
thought about everything,
and long story short
is I think it had a lot
to do with the whole skeumorphic
shift to flat design.
If you think about it, we
all spend all this time
nudging a pixel to get
that perfect texture,
or that perfect shadow,
or whatever it might be.
And frankly, how
the user interacted
with that perfect look,
if you will, came second.
I think when Apple kind
of threw that out frankly,
shifted to let's
keep things flat,
but now let's focus on the
experience a little more--
the motion and the actual
interaction-- all of a sudden
that put it front and center.
So it's no coincidence that
for us, when we went out,
that was the pain point.
No one said to me,
how do I make a better
texture for my mobile app?
That was gone.
What came to me is, how do I
get this nuanced interaction
completely, precisely
how I want it to be,
and how do I do that without
investing a lot of time
in engineering and
design, frankly?
Or at least can I iterate
my design of the interaction
many times over?
Because I always like
to say, by the way,
designers like to iterate.
They need to.
Engineers do not.
They do not want to rewrite
their code over and over,
and I think that's fundamentally
the big shift, basically.
BRANDON WALKIN:
Yeah, I don't know.
It's interesting.
Like when I started seeing
a shift was when we actually
shipped chat heads
and Facebook Home.
It's funny.
Before that, I was
trying to tell everybody
about Quartz Composer.
I'm like, it's
this amazing tool.
It looks crazy, but you can
actually use it to build these
really cool interactions
that you otherwise couldn't.
And no one wanted to hear it.
But yeah, when we
shipped Facebook home,
it had a bunch of pretty
interesting interactions
in there all done
in Quartz Composer.
And then I think one of our
design directors, Julie Zhuo,
wrote a blog post where she
kind of talked about some
of the design process,
and she mentioned
that yeah, the whole thing
was done in Quartz Composer.
And so that's when I
saw this immediate shift
where people started thinking
about interactive tools.
I think that was a
big change there.
NOAH LEVIN: So I want to
shift gears a little bit
and talk a little bit
about the actual creation
experience, the experience of
opening up one of these tools
and creating something,
and how the difference
between these tools
might actually
affect the outcome of
what you're producing.
They're very different, if
you've used each of these.
Some of them are more visual.
Some of them are code-based.
They have a different approach
to how you might do it.
So to start, there's no
one on the panel that
really works on a
timeline-based tool.
No one here really-- something
like Flash or After Effects.
Why don't we think-- is
there a reason for that?
Why don't we have
timeline-based tools
versus something more free-form?
KOEN BOK: Well, if you're
building an interactive tool,
then time is not a constant.
Stuff like state is
shifting throughout time,
and it's going to go
through different states
every time you use the
app and stuff like that.
So a timeline isn't
very efficient,
if you're trying to build
these longer interactions.
Maybe just a show
of a small thing,
and I think that's the most
obvious reason that that
wouldn't be the best model
to pick for these new tools.
NOAH LEVIN: But why
do we think that?
Even with that being the case,
a lot of people-- at least
in my experience, and
even seeing at Google--
are gravitating still to
the timeline-based tools.
What is it about them that
are making people use them?
KOEN BOK: Well, I
mean a lot of people
build a knowledge
around these tools,
and I think they do
particular things very well.
And they're still very valuable.
It's not that we're going
to move After Effects
out of the market with
our interactive tools.
I think they're going to
live next to each other,
and we'll slowly start
taking more of the stuff
that they're really good at
and taking that into our apps,
I think.
PAUL COLTON: One
thing I'll add is,
time, at least for
interaction, implies
you know the exact flow that
your user's going to take.
Right?
Interaction by definition
means it's random,
and I think that's fundamentally
why timeline doesn't work.
And you can imagine, we've
been asked countless times,
put a timeline in there.
And we're like, interaction
is not about timelines.
You can't dictate what
your user's going to do.
They might reverse the order in
which they move their finger.
You're not going to
know that ahead of time.
ADAM DEBRECZENI: Yeah, one of
the big things in Form is we
were debating this internally
whether to do timelines
or something a lot
more interactive.
And we thought that removing
as much abstraction as possible
is really important when you're
trying to think of new ideas,
because if you conceive of
an idea in After Effects,
and you load it on your phone,
and you can't actually interact
with it, there's a
level of telephone
that you give to the engineer.
Versus a system
that works exactly
like it would in production--
lets you actually
tweak little variables
as you're using it.
So we have this
silly thing where
if you're dragging
around an image,
you can actually adjust
the spring friction when
you're dragging the image.
Or you could have
like three iPhones,
and they could all have
people interacting with it
with different
amount of springs.
It's really difficult to
fine tune stuff like that
when it's a pre-baked movie.
NOAH LEVIN: Yeah.
That's a really point.
I'm wondering, though, how
do these UIs actually--
particularly for Form and
Origami, that a lot of people
have mentioned they feel one of
the reasons they haven't tried
it out yet is maybe there's
a bit of a learning curve.
It's a different
way of thinking.
It's something that
they haven't done yet.
How do we help that a bit?
How do we teach
people this new tool?
Is it the right
UI, or do you think
your UIs might change over time?
BRANDON WALKIN: Yeah,
so it's worth noting,
Origami looks the way
it does, because it's
an extension on Quartz Composer.
I wasn't given a team
of engineers and people
to go and make a
tool from scratch.
It was just something
I had to build
in a scrappy way
in my spare time,
just because I needed to do it.
And so that's definitely why
it looks the way it does.
But I mean, in terms
of-- what I think's
actually really important
is the fact that you
can build anything
in Quartz Composer.
Like it's completely unbounded,
and I think that's important,
because when you're
trying to be creative,
and you actually might
want to do something
that the maker of the
tool hadn't thought about.
And if you can't get those ideas
out there, it's a huge problem.
So I do think there
are definitely
huge problems to the
Quartz Composer interface.
It's intimidating.
A lot of people
find it confusing.
And yeah, there are a bunch of
other issues as well, but yeah.
So I think if I were
to start from scratch,
it would look way different.
But it would still
have that capability
to let people build anything
that they can imagine.
NOAH LEVIN: I think there's
a really interesting contrast
there between what
you're mentioning,
which is you have this
kind of free-form canvas.
In the same way that you have
this big canvas in something
like Sketch or Photoshop,
you have almost a blank page,
and you can create anything.
But with that comes a little
bit of hesitation, right?
Everyone has that little
bit of blank page,
you just don't know
where to start.
And actually I'm excited by
the contrast on this panel,
because I find something
like Invision, for example,
there are more
constraints to it.
There's a little bit
more-- if you've used it,
it's a little bit simpler
for you to get going.
There's not the same kinds
of questions from customers
that I've heard about
that are saying,
I don't know how to
start with this tool.
But on the other
hand, how does that
affect what you can create?
This one, for example,
you can tie together
screens a lot
easier, and you can
allow things to slide left
and right or up and down.
How have you found the
approach of having a simpler,
approachable tool versus
a more flexible one?
CLARK VALBERG: I think
I look at product design
as being three
different dimensions.
So there's the
aesthetic dimension,
the interactive dimension,
and then there's the story.
So with any of these
products, the focus
of the product kind of
biases you towards a focus
on one of those dimensions.
So with Invision,
the focus is story.
We all agree on aesthetics.
I think we're not
wire forming tools,
so we all agree that
you need aesthetics
to be able to have a broad
reach with your user engagement.
But if the story is
why the user showed up,
and the story is where you
want to bring them in the end,
I look at that as
being fundamentally
different than engineering
an interaction, which
I think is also important.
But I think it's
something that has
to happen after the story has
been nailed down, because most
of the business
strategy, which is really
what we do as designers, and
I think this also conspires
with the whole changing role
of designers and designers
just doing more,
being more involved,
and taking a greater leadership
role in the product design
process, and even a
strategic business level.
But when you're
there, and you're
thinking about what
the business needs,
the story has to be primary.
The interactions are there as an
accompaniment to the aesthetics
to create comfort as the
user responds to the system.
Which is also important.
PAUL COLTON: I just wanted
to add, from our take,
I don't think-- you
don't require complexity
to build something complex,
and I think, think of a pencil.
It gives you complete
creative freedom.
Yeah, it's one of the
simplest tools you could have.
I think for us, that's
been our approach.
How can we build the
absolute simplest tool
to then also absolutely
not hamper any creativity?
And to touch a little
bit on your point
too, I think also
for all of us, is
I think we strive-- I'll speak
for everyone, at least we do--
we strive that our tool
doesn't influence what
the final product's
going to be like.
That's when we
know we've failed.
If everything you build looks
like it was built in Pixate,
then we've done something wrong.
We want to make sure that the
end result looks like what
you wanted to build,
and we were just
that pencil that made it happen.
ADAM DEBRECZENI: Just to add
on to Brandon's point-- sorry,
I cut you off, Koen.
One of the big things
that we focused
on with the open
canvas, the fact
that you can build
anything, is it's
a great amount of difficulty.
So you first open up
Form-- blank canvas.
It's really intimidating.
The main thing that we focused
on while designing patches
is how do we make this the most
consistent system possible?
And because everything
is consistent,
there's only outputs
and only inputs,
data flow is always
the same way,
you can build a lot
of reusable chunks.
So you can build
your own patches.
And because you can
reuse a lot of it,
and you can build
your own patches,
the canvas actually
ends up shrinking a lot.
Because it's actually
a very concise canvas,
it makes it very easy to parse.
And because it's parsable,
you can actually-- well,
because you can
build anything, you
can actually build like
a hamburger menu patch
if you really wanted to.
And it's still made
out of the same 20
patches that Form ships with.
NOAH LEVIN: One
thing that's starting
to come up that
I'm curious about
is Clark had
mentioned that there's
a big emphasis in
Invision for storytelling,
and at other points
of our conversation
here, we're talking
a bit about moments
of openness and execution.
Is there a point in the process,
in the design process, that you
think your tool is
meant to be used in?
Can it be used at any point?
Are your tools all possible for
storytelling in a higher level?
Is it just about execution
polish and detail?
KOEN BOK: Well,
I think that ties
into the flexibility
of your tool.
So for example, if you would
take the linear approach
for any of these tools, you
would be pretty much confined
in this one thing, like
this microinteraction.
But once you get to code or
visual or signal flow program,
you can do anything.
So it's pretty-- like in Framer,
it's really-- it's not easy,
but it's doable to set
up really huge apps,
basically build entire
applications in there.
So for us I think
we often get defined
as sort of like a
microinteraction tool,
because you focus on
these small things.
But it's actually, I think we're
one of the few tools where it's
possible to build out
entire app experiences.
BRANDON WALKIN: Go for it.
Oh, OK.
Yeah.
So at Facebook at
least, we started
using Quartz Composer
really early in the process.
And so whether it's like a new
app that we're thinking about,
when we go and
pitch this to Mark,
he's expecting to see a full
prototype that is polished,
that has animations,
that has interactions,
that's thought through.
And obviously
sketching plays a role.
We all have
sketchbooks and draw.
It's very low
friction to do that,
but yeah, I think it really
does help tell the story when
the thing that you're showing
looks like how it will actually
look to users.
CLARK VALBERG: I think
a pretty major caveat
there is that investment
is the enemy of creativity.
The more you invest in any
particular direction, the more
biased, naturally, you
are to moving ever further
in that direction.
So when you're dealing
with these multiple layers
of abstraction, you
have your design,
then you have your
interactive components,
and maybe you have two different
tools, so you're in Photoshop,
and you're in one
of these tools.
You have to be very
careful that you
don't end up down a rabbit hole.
It just makes you either
personally resistant
to the change that
you'd like to make,
or the changes that happen as a
natural process of discovering
what the user really needs.
And I think that there's
also a really important
philosophical difference between
articulation and discovery.
So if you have an
idea, if we took,
let's say Facebook
Paper or something,
and we knew that we wanted
to take that animation
and design it, to engineer
it, to make it look exactly
like that with all the
subtle nuances, that's
a certain process.
That's a certain domain.
If you're not sure
what you want, and you
know that the user
came from point A,
and they're ending
up at point Z,
and there are all these
different points in between,
and you want to
understand how to deal
with the gentle volley of
interaction with that user,
I think that you need to stay
really flexible, because three
screens in your app
could turn into one.
Or one screen could
turn into three,
depending on the direction
that you make strategically.
NOAH LEVIN: Yeah.
I'm going to move things
along just a little bit,
just so we can make sure we
touch on one of the topics
that I think we
talked to be about one
of the most interesting
things we look at
is where is this really going?
Is it going to be
one of these tools
that we end up
using predominately
in the same way you
could argue something
like Photoshop or
Sketch is done?
There's not a huge amount
of disparity in the tools
we've used in other contexts,
yet here these tools
are very different.
And you have a lot of choice
now, and in some ways,
you can almost find that
paralyzing as a way to start.
And so just as kind of a
final topic to touch on ,
let's start with, is it
going to be one tool?
Do you think that it's just
one of us standing after this
or something, and
it's just going
to be one tool you
approach, or is it
a combination of these things?
Can you use these
things together?
Yeah.
Where do we think this
is going in that sense?
KOEN BOK: I think
it's good to have
choice, finally, as designers.
We've been coming
from five to 10 years
where if you were designing, you
were probably using Photoshop,
and everybody around
was using Photoshop.
So I'm pretty happy
to get rid of that,
although Photoshop
is a nice tool.
But I'm also pretty sure that
all the different directions--
like it's weird that we all
have such different approaches,
like from UI-based to
visual programming to like
actual codes.
And I think the real
tool in the future
will probably be a
blend of some of those
in a really smart balance,
where maybe you give up
some flexibility for a
really low learning curve,
or maybe not at all.
We'll see.
But I would definitely be
surprised if in five years,
we would still be debating
if visual program would
be better than code
or better than a UI.
That will solve
itself over time.
BRANDON WALKIN: I actually
do think designers will
be expected to know
prototyping tools.
KOEN BOK: [INAUDIBLE].
BRANDON WALKIN: Just
like every designer
is expected to know
Photoshop or Sketch,
and designers are
really good at that.
Like you can go on
Dribble, and you
can see a whole range of
different types of visuals,
right?
You're actually not seeing
that with interaction.
What you normally see
is people will be really
creative with visuals,
because they know how
to use those tools,
but then when it
comes to how the app
is actually structured
and the specific
interactions, they'll
pull stuff from some applets
out there and maybe another app,
combine them together.
But you really don't see
the same sort of creativity
in interactions.
And so I think once people start
learning these new interaction
tools, and once they
become more advanced,
easier to learn,
easier to use, I
think that's going to be huge.
ADAM DEBRECZENI: And if
you really think about it,
we've been talking and
interacting with computers
the same way for like 30 years.
It's been [INAUDIBLE].
They've been talking back
to us through consoles.
And there's been
almost a sense of dogma
laid down with how we
actually build things.
And for the first time, we're
actually empowering designers
to go out and essentially make
their designs interactive,
and we have no dogma right now.
So it's really
fascinating that we
have Wiziwig,
visual programming,
and textual-based programming.
It's interesting right now
that we have no expectations,
so I think that's why there's
all these different directions.
CLARK VALBERG: I
think the thing that's
going to precipitate
all of this change
is the changing role
of the designer.
So I think we've seen a
convergence around everybody
just generally describing
themselves as a designer,
because nobody wanted to
be just a UX person or just
a visual person.
I see in the future, and
I see this happening now,
even companies in this room,
where you have a product
designer, who really thinks
more like a product manager.
And I think product managers
that also think like designers,
and I think best of
both will probably
have that kind of mindset--
strategically-driven, needs
of the business
at the forefront.
Leadership skills--
understanding
how to engage end users, how
to take a lot of feedback
and sort it, and throw away
the stuff that isn't good,
but interpret it emphatically.
And then, perhaps,
people who are more
focused on the interactive
layer, the more subtle nuances
of an application,
and I see those people
sitting in the room as
part of an ecosystem of how
a product is designed in an
open, kind of socialized way.
What I don't see is the
traditional hand-off process
where a designer or a few
designers go into a room,
they build something,
and then there's
this cadence of design review.
I think that humped
design review
cadence will flatten out.
And the design that's
being worked on
will be socialized
and more available
and engaged beyond
the design department,
kind of through the life of the
product development process.
NOAH LEVIN: Yeah.
It's even interesting
how these tools
might affect our
role in that process
and change the
pieces in which we're
involved throughout that cycle.
We did want to just
pause here for questions,
and see if there are anything
that you guys were wondering
that we can help answer.
And there's people,
I think, with mics
that are walking around
and can help you out.
So I guess just raise
your hand if there's
some kind of burning thing on
your mind, and we'll go around.
Oh, my god, we have questions.
So whoever's closest,
right over there.
Whoever gets the mic is going
to be the one that gets to ask.
AUDIENCE: How do you guys
feel, or what do you guys
think about the
dichotomy of tools
that starts to emerge when
you have a tool for visuals
versus a tool for
interactions, and like maybe
even a different means?
How do you deal with data
in those prototypes as well?
Because I personally would love
to have a tool where I can just
go and just focus on one thing
and design an entire product,
versus having to flip around
through different tools
depending on their
strengths and weaknesses.
PAUL COLTON: I'll
just say, I think
one challenge that we've tried
to stay, for example, away
from is anywhere away
from your core product
becomes a slippery slope.
In other words, we
were joking last night.
Next thing after square,
you want a triangle.
And now you're going to want a
circle, and all of a sudden you
want Sketch.
Now on the other hand,
now you want a timeline,
now you want compositing, and
now you have After Effects.
Though the problem is
how far do we keep going?
I think for us, what
we've decided to say
is, there's a big gap in
the workflow right now.
Regardless of the tool you
pick for your processes
of building these
interactions, that's
the hole we're trying to fill.
We're trying to say,
you've designed over here,
and you want to
deliver over there.
There's a big hole
in the middle.
We're going to fill that hole.
I think we, at least
speaking for Pixate,
we have to be
careful we don't keep
slipping more and more
into, oh, by the way,
now we're your design tool,
now your pixel editing tool,
we're your deployment tool.
You know what I'm saying.
So there's a give
and take, basically.
I don't think one
tool can do it all.
I don't think you want one tool
to do it all, because if so,
you wouldn't have Sketch.
CLARK VALBERG: I think
aesthetic authoring will happen
in the desktop probably in the
incumbent tool set, Photoshop,
Sketch.
But I think that the
process of bringing that
to life and kind of
moving that through time
in an interactive way,
which really prototyping
is just a storytelling
tool, but I
see that converging
in one place.
NOAH LEVIN: Let's take
another question just
to make sure we get
a few more out there.
Yeah, whoever you
guys want to walk up
to you that's closer to you.
There you go.
AUDIENCE: Last time I used
a visual prototyping tool,
it involved a lot of
logic and decision-making
that normally doesn't happen
until you get into code.
And that sort of gave me this
grandiose vision of one day
maybe we'll be able to
build apps completely
through some of these
prototyping tools.
How far away do you think
we are from that happening?
ADAM DEBRECZENI: I
think we're-- sorry.
I think we're very, very close.
The reason Form took so
long is our foundation
is you could actually run these
compositions in production.
That's something that
we're working toward,
and it's not that far out.
So even though it's
very challenging,
and there's a lot of
logic, some of that,
unfortunately, is necessary
to cover all the edge cases.
So there is a very
short-term future
where you can just do file
export and load it up in Xcode,
and give it to your engineer, so
there's no lost in translation.
CLARK VALBERG: I
think generating code
is very different than
architecting software.
So even if you have a tool
that can spit out some code
that's descriptive at a
programmatic level of the thing
that you see on the screen,
how that ties together--
frameworks.
I mean there's probably at least
some developers in the room,
right?
It is way more complicated
than just generating code.
All of this has to
be glued together.
There has to be
some infrastructure
to tie it all together, and
that takes hard decisions.
And even how that happens is a
very rapidly evolving process.
I mean it's a whole field.
And so I think it would be
really difficult for a tool
to generate an app
you could ship.
And I think that'll
probably be a--
BRANDON WALKIN: I think there
are all these complexities
that you have to deal
with when you're building
an app, versus what you actually
want to be thinking about when
you're prototyping.
For example, when
you're prototyping,
it may not be worth
the effort to make
sure your prototype works
in every single language
or on every single screen size.
That's going to take
a bunch of time,
and if it's not going to help
you solve the problem that you
were originally trying to
solve, you don't want to do it.
I think in addition
to that, when
you're building apps--
say you're building
an app for iOS--
you probably want
to use the system frameworks.
You want to use UI kit.
That gives you a
bunch of benefits
like it's immediately
accessible if you're
visually impaired
or hearing impaired.
The Apple just kind of work.
And I think if
the tool just sort
of renders in its
own environment,
you're going to miss
out on a lot of that.
KOEN BOK: Yeah.
And having said that, I
also-- I'm with Brandon.
I think that it's too big and
probably the wrong problem
to tackle to go
from your prototype
to the final product at once.
But there's a lot of in-between
that we can actually improve,
I feel.
I think a lot of you are
still sending ZIP files
up and down with resources
through your engineers.
That's kind of silly.
I mean we could do
better than that.
I think there's a lot of obvious
stuff like matching inputs
for spring physics,
maybe even mapping out
positions like states that
we can maybe send down
to the iOS engineer that
can also use a state machine
and can reuse all that stuff.
And I think that's the
obvious stuff that we still
have to solve and
haven't, and that's
what I'm going to try to
focus on in the beginning.
CLARK VALBERG: I just
have one warning.
The minute you find yourself
heading up the investment
slope, and the day you walk into
a meeting with VPs or product
people or your own
team, and you're
angry at the person
who gave you feedback,
suggesting you should
change everything, not
because he's wrong, but
because it means that you have
to go and redo something
you spent a week doing,
be very afraid.
That's not where you want to be.
NOAH LEVIN: We probably time
for about one more question.
If there's more
things-- I think there
were more hands than that,
feel free to either tweet,
add us, or just find everyone
during the happy hour later,
something like that.
But I think we have time for
just maybe one more quick one.
Yeah.
Wherever you are.
AUDIENCE: Hey.
Alexander from Inbox.
I have a question
for all of you.
I think it's amazing
all of these tools
enabling all different
types of content creation,
but what ends up happening
is that over the course
of a project, all these
different types of content
get siloed into these services.
So the more you use, everything
gets fragmented and spread out.
So I just was wondering what
your thoughts were on that.
Does that makes sense?
KOEN BOK: Yeah.
I guess it's a
downside of choice.
Right?
AUDIENCE: I don't mean
like similar tools.
I mean like each
one of these tools
that you use is specialized
in a different way.
KOEN BOK: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So it's come to the
point where we're using 10
cloud-based tools right now,
and we have to go to each one
of these services to either
export content and put it
somewhere or host
it and share a link,
so I was just wondering if you
guys think that's a problem,
or--
CLARK VALBERG: Thankfully,
Adobe has actually
acquired all these guys.
PAUL COLTON: We're all merging.
Well, I think
obviously integration
with the other
tools is important.
I mean obviously,
like that's why
earlier the point about
rectangles and circles
really isn't a joke.
The point is we don't want
to get into that stuff.
Right?
The idea is you know
how to whether it
be vector or
bitmap-based, you're
doing that somewhere else.
We're not asking you
to redo anything.
We're saying, bring that in
here, and when you're done,
it'll go out to there,
wherever that might be.
I hear you, though, that
movement of data is a pain.
And hopefully, I think either
some of us already have,
frankly.
Others have already dealt
with import and exporting.
We'll look that
and just continue
to streamline the workflow,
I think, is the answer.
ADAM DEBRECZENI: Yeah.
And just I'm totally
trolling at this point,
but we have a JavaScript
patch in form,
so you could just
load a JavaScript
prototype in our tool.
But that's not going
to help with your case.
NOAH LEVIN: Cool.
I think we're out of time.
But thank you so
much for being here,
and I hope this is, again, like
the start of more conversations
about these tools and
what other gaps there
are in our design
process, and how
we can solve them
with more tools.
So, yeah.
Thanks a lot.
And we'll see you around.